and in 1962 brock was a regular before
his 23rd birthday struggled as we all
know in the two seasons with the cubs
and usually he was reminded of what he
wasn't and rarely told what he could do
and it's a date a watershed moment in
cardinals history june 15
1964
the cardinals traded 20-game winner
ernie broglio
and the cardinals got that man lou brock
and the rest is history
rest in peace lou
and we'll be thinking of you today
we all love you starting picture for the
cubs the professor kyle hendricks and he
comes at you this way a lot of change
ups and sinkers occasionally he'll
elevate a four-seam fastball his average
at that time was 205 and that's what
he's doing on the road shooting gaps
hustling out of the box he'll take a
wide turn around first base and stop
there lead off single colton law
drives this one the other way and it is
just beneath the basket he almost hit
another lead off homer as it is it's a
double
[Applause]
start
that's a base hit let's see if half will
score nope
nobody out will venable will stop him in
third
two on nobody out for anthony rizzo
tag applied
4-3 double play runs scores one-nothing
no rbi for rizzo hap is in and then the
cubs have the
lead backhanded by deyoung gonna be
close safe he beat it deung waded back
on that
and didn't hit it all that hard it'll be
an infield single because of his hustle
it's been the story line here today
there's a lot of balls right on the
screws
little blooper will drop in
ground ball toward the hole diving stop
carpenter throw to second and they do
get an out
it's a big first out for the cardinals
meanwhile the cubs have them at first
and third with rizzo coming up
high fly ball left center gymnast ready
to tag vader
and he dropped it
and they're gonna give him the out
[Applause]
it'll end up being a sac fly
and it's two to nothing
and now he's eight for 15. just takes it
the other way and a base hit and the
tang run will come to the plate ground
ball let's see if they can turn it oh
that's nifty
they do
five six three on the double play
henders getting that ground ball when he
needed one
kb in the shift backhanded flip set that
one to sweet georgia brown
five six three actions
[Music]
maven cranks one to left
and it's gonna roll to the wall
[Applause]
two really good at bats
boy if not for that win he'd be halfway
to a cycle here today
a single in a run
that is going to get into left
and maven's going to score
kittness racing to second throw to the
plate laid three nothing
cubs have really struggled with runners
in scoring position especially here at
light but connectness delivers with just
a little
pooch the other way
carpenter
another close one safe at first as
goldsmith was off the bag he's on again
three times on the ground in the infield
three reaches we'll see if this is a
base hit or an e5
and that ball will go on the left bias
will make third schwarber to
[Applause]
back second back fielding mistakes by
saint louis putting the cubs in business
they've got two men in scoring position
wilson contreras at the plate the
infield in for st louis contreras swings
rips one fair ball down the left field
line baez scores schwarber races around
third he's coming home a two-run single
for wilson contreras and the cubs extend
the lead five-nothing over the cardinals
here in the fifth five-nothing cubs lead
kyle hendricks has been so good at
wrigley field throughout his career
hendricks dealing in this ball game as
goldschmidt delivers with a base hit
into left center
and the lead off hit to start playing
here in the top of the seventh
and a fly ball
out to right maybe
kind of hesitated just a bit and it
drops in for a base hit i'm sure weeders
wants to get more than anything that
first hit just be done with it and
weiders hits it off the end of the bat
and there it is his first hit of the
season that'll drive in miller
the cardinals get on the board to make
it five to one
and a smile for matt waiters
speaking of the smile of lou brock
there's a big one for matt wieders third
time hendricks has gone at least seven
this season and
strike three called
kyle's third strikeout in the first
since the third inning
swinging a miss good comeback
back-to-back strikeouts for hendricks to
finish the eighth cubs lead by four
fly ball to center ian happ is there
comes when
rowan whitt goes one two three in the
night
season series ends up five apiece all
ten played
here at wrigley field and the standings
are up to date
as the cubs now have that two and a half
game lead
in the central